welcome to this video playing blitz
rider again I've played him just a
number of games ago not the last one
it's not done just one or two games ago
okay the UM ruler PES Spanish opening
exchange why i play my fish should be
seven lines blue specialty nothing super
great but it leads to slightly unusual
positions in the in the exchange yeah if
I've is an interesting move I mean I
don't mind this because it's it's
provoking move that wide strategically
speaking does not want to play v5 but
it's never less played quite often
against me okay how do I continue maybe
Bishop decent yes e six though this is
really something to take into account
maybe start there anyway and go for long
castling if I've it's not that wide
strategically wants to play and that
also not because um it puts so much
stuff here on the dark squares and I get
a very good light squared blockade with
night h6 now for example um the only
thing is or maybe i can go mighty 70
which is simpler
okay let's go here that's very
comparable to them to the Berlin the
Berlin Wall the only difference of
intended sir it's a substantial
difference is that i still can castle
and very often I get in non castling
let's see um how this is going to
proceed Bishop f2 looks very normal not
sure why he wants to go see five I mean
b6 I play anyway so interesting that i
didn't expect of course ok I take d4
takes on the seven droop do you want now
this is not great so let's take it what
what's the point
I will definitely take it check okay so
I'm just uh just a piece up here let's
see how to win it convincingly them it's
a very safe position only look um fi of
course is the thing to watch out for
want to double on the G file and then
maybe get the King 22 to the default d7
or something to avoid this opposition
here from the rook
I already thought that this if I've move
was interesting I thought Billy Bishop
b5 was something that he that he can try
pen okay he's he's only six let me just
do a sidestep possibly 96 check
yeah I'm pretty pretty relaxed here
because all my pieces are covered it's
always a good policy if you're on our
material up on yeah not even only then
it's always good to have all your pieces
covered and here everything's covered so
very unlikely that's something something
I'm technically problematic is going to
happen okay maybe I want to want to win
on g2 we have this is really you can get
the bishop to see 60 rock d 5 would be
also quite a good pin
and rg3 is falling check
yeah the game God has been won by
resigning it's very true nevertheless um
and it's very this very little chance
here that like SM is screwing this up
check maybe I'm stalemate or something
check blundering the bishop I have a
cave
check check check check check check mate
yeah I know probably he just had some
sort of black out here with Bishop g7 at
term it would have been interesting to
play this middle game with the end game
2 and then aged 5 it's quite funny that
that stock fish gives wider white a
slight advantage here which is yeah we'd
search those shows that the berlin wall
structure would be a good choice against
against the computer if someone's still
trying to play the computer because
black has absolutely no problems here
absolutely nothing i would actually
prefer black but maybe this is an
overstatement simply because the dark
web located some is so nice at the light
square blockade I'm sorry that the night
on on when a 5-bit should be six be 65
just a very comfortable position he can
put a knight on d5 and take on his six
but this end game type is known to be
perfectly okay for black yeah that he
played them played this I thought that
maybe he was trying to just make this
Bishop more active and tried to play for
for some sort of it's not working but I
thought this was the idea that he had
some sort of miscalculation here from
Bishop she said maybe just overlook the
night after that I was just just a piece
up alright thanks for watching